und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber einen
schönen guten abend nichts geht mehr in
frankreich heute revolutionen gehen
menschen auf die straße wenn sie nichts
mehr zu verlieren haben in ganz
frankreich vor allem in paris sind
hunderttausende auf der straße weil sie
etwas zu verlieren haben ein
rentensystem nämlich dass verglichen mit
anderen europäischen ländern ziemlich
großzügig ist für manche in einem alter
einsetzt indem deutsche beschäftigte
noch ein drittel ihres arbeitslebens vor
sich haben und auch die renten liegen im
schnitt deutlich höher
nicht für alle aber für genügend um die
straßen zu füllen und verkehr büros und
schulen lahmzulegen
präsident ma korn der schon viel
durchgedrückt hat steckt jetzt in seinem
härtesten und wohl entscheidenden test
als reformer christel hass berichtet vor
einem einsamen zug im pariser
nordbahnhof gibt eine gruppe von
streikenden eisenbahnern schon mal den
ton an für diesen tag makro halt die
klappe rufen sie mittendrin klebriger jo
seit 16 jahren bei der bahn
die geplante rentenreform macht ihn
wütend und unsere rente ist unantastbar
ja ich kann früher in rente gehen dafür
arbeite ich aber auch an vielen
wochenenden und an vielen feiertagen
generalstreik in frankreich und das seit
dem frühen morgen fast keine metro mehr
in paris landesweit zehn züge mangelware
wer dennoch zur arbeit wollte musste
sich alternativen suchen viele schulen
sind geschlossen in krankenhäusern gibt
es nur notdienst und dazu im ganzen land
über 800.000 menschen auf der straße
allein 65.000 sind es in paris dort
finden wie xavi wieder der wie alle hier
entschlossen ist die ungeliebte
rentenreform zu fall zu bringen
wir geben nicht auf bis die reform
zurückgezogen wird wir machen weiter
notfalls bis weihnachten
und wenn sie morgen vom tisch ist können
wir morgen auf
bis zum wochenende so viel steht fest
werden streik und proteste weitergehen
alle sind da die rentner die jungen das
zeigt wie schlecht das projekt ist wir
sagen so geht es nicht
eine heikle situation für den
präsidenten die rentenreform ist emanuel
macros ehrgeizigstes projekt er will die
42 verschiedene rentenkassen
vereinheitlichen und privilegien
abschaffen
in frankreich liegt das gesetzliche
renteneintrittsalter bei 62 jahren die
vielen sonder systeme zum beispiel für
eisenbahner oder bestimmte angestellte
im öffentlichen dienst erlauben aber
einen ruhestand schon ab mitte 50
die durchschnittsrente liegt bei zirka
1600 50 euro im monat
jetzt also die reform
die regierung betont dass über die
inhalte noch verhandelt wird doch den
druck der straße will sie nicht
nachgeben
es ist normal dass es fragen und
widerstände gibt aber das hält mich
keine sekunde davon ab diese reform zu
ende zu bringen
ich bin keineswegs vor angst erstarrt
doch klar ist auch es geht um viel in
diesem machtkampf um die glaubwürdigkeit
von regierung und präsident
und wie bei so vielen demonstrationen in
frankreich gibt es auch heute wieder
ausschreitungen und polizeieinsätze doch
die gewalt war weniger heftig als
befürchtet
beim thema rente allerdings wird es wohl
noch öfter zur sache gehen in
deutschland hingegen geht der politische
trend gerade eher in richtung ausbau als
abbau von sozialleistungen in richtung
sparziele aufgeben wenn es um geld geht
und sparziele verschärfen wenn es um
klimaschutz geht das ist jedenfalls der
genosse trend den die spd mitglieder
wählen wollten als sie olaf scholz ihr
kreuz verweigert und beim team walter
borjans esken gesetzt haben
in den nächsten tagen wird man sehen wie
viel von dieser kehrtwende von nikolaus
ist coco aus dem parteitag der spd
übersteht vorab berichtet andreas weiter
eine szene café in berlin mitte am abend
die spd linke stimmt sich auf dem
parteitag ein
ich freue mich total es kann unser
aufbruchs parteitag werden wenn wir
daraus machen und ich glaube das hat
richtig gut
die hoffnung mit dem parteitag die hier
so ungeliebte große koalition zu beenden
ist geschwunden in den letzten tagen
doch aufgeben noch lange nicht ich habe
mit dem mitglieder votum am samstag
schon die hoffnung verbunden dass jetzt
der inhaltliche und personelle wechsel
kommt also dass das weite suchen ende
hat am mittag ein paar kilometer südlich
im willy-brandt-haus der
spd-parteizentrale länger als geplant
ring die parteispitze um den leitantrag
für den parteitag dann treten die beiden
designierten parteichefs vor die kameras
aber sie werden nachvollziehen können
dass es nicht die reine lehre zahlen
können dessen wovon wir überzeugt sind
das ist das wesen eines kompromisses
aber es geht in die richtige richtung
und deswegen sind wir sehr zufrieden
damit als großer kritiker gestartet
wollen auch sie jetzt keine krokodile
auf dem parteitag stellen sie auch nicht
mehr grundsätzlich in frage
nach verhandlungen mit der union soll es
allerdings schon geben wie sieht es
eigentlich weiter mit dem klimaschutz
ich glaube niemand würde uns nachsehen
wenn wir sagen dann machen wir einfach
jetzt ein haken dran und damit hat es
sich
es muss weitergehen mit der frage
massiver investitionen in die
öffentliche infrastruktur
und es muss auch weitergehen mit
arbeitsmarktpolitischen entscheidungen
also etwa vor allem einen mindestlohn
von 12 euro anzustreben wie die neue
parteispitze außer dem aussehen soll ist
auch schon weitgehend klar
klara geywitz zusammen mit olaf scholz
im rennen um den vorsitz unterlegen soll
vize werden ebenso anke rehlinger aus
dem saarland
favorit der neuen parteispitze für den
dritten stellvertreter wohl kevin
kühnert juso-chef und kroko kritiker
galionsfigur der allerdings mit der
interview aussage man müsse sich das gut
überlegen mit dem ausstieg für
verwirrung sorgte
und er hat einen prominenten
konkurrenten hubertus heil
arbeitsminister und kroko befürworter es
geht ja darum die kräfte zu bündeln die
spd auch zusammenzuhalten weil die spd
eine wichtige rolle für unser land hat
sie hat verantwortung aber sie wird auch
perspektiven über diese große koalition
hinaus entwickeln müssen wir auch die
nächste bundestagswahl
die parteilinke sieht perspektiven nach
wie vor außerhalb der groko will mit
einem eigenen initiativantrag der
parteiführung in die parade fahren
wir glauben dass in einer großen
koalition wir einen erneuerungsprozess
nicht hinbekommen und um überleben zu
können also spd brauchen wir einen
erneuerungsprozess und da hat das heißt
in letzter konsequenz raus aus der
großen koalition in dieser halle tief im
berliner westen beginnt morgen der
spd-parteitag überraschungen nicht
ausgeschlossen
klimaschützer in der spd haben heute
neuen zündstoff für ihre debatte auf dem
parteitag in die hand bekommen die
quelle ist das umweltbundesamt das ist
teil des spd-geführten
umweltministeriums und dort haben die
experten schon im sommer mal
durchgerechnet was wirklich passieren
müsste damit der sektor verkehr
verantwortet vom csu-minister scheuer
seinen vollen pflicht beitrag leisten
würde
zur co2 einsparung die ergebnisse dieser
studie lassen alles was den koalition
gerade beschlossen hat lächerlich
ungenügend aussehen zündstoff also
herausgegeben mit einem spitzen gefühl
für politisches timing dara hassanzadeh
der verkehr ist das größte sorgenkind
der bundesregierung was ihre
selbstgesteckten klimaziele angeht neuer
autos verbrauchen weniger aber es gibt
von ihnen immer mehr und sie fahren auch
mehr kilometer
zudem nimmt der gütertransport per lkw
weiter zu seit 1990 hat sich der co2
ausstoß auf deutschen straßen kaum
verringert bis 2030 will die
bundesregierung den ausstoß auf 98
millionen tonnen co2 reduzieren dieses
ziel erreiche man nur mit radikalen
maßnahmen sagt das umweltbundesamt eine
heute veröffentlichte studie fordert die
abschaffung der pendlerpauschale eine
energie steuer von 205 euro pro tonne
co2 statt der bisher beschlossenen zehn
euro was diesel um 70 cent und benzin um
47 cent pro liter verteuern würde zudem
ein tempolimit von 120 stundenkilometern
wenn wir das große ziel vor augen haben
das klima zu schützen
dann kommen wir auch an solchen kleinen
änderungen eigenen lebensstil nicht
vorbei und ich möchte gerne das ist als
eine dekade der verkehrsmenge betrachtet
wird und nicht ein ende von heute auf
morgen sondern wir müssen den menschen
reinen wein einschenken wohin soll es
gehen was unsere richtung damit wir das
ziel auch schaffen
scharfe kritik an der studie
bundesverkehrsminister scheuer die
bürger erneut mit verzicht verbot und
verteuerung aller bundesumweltamt in
panik zu versetzen ist der falsche
ansatz bundesumweltministerin schulze
kannte die studie schon im sommer
doch sie hielt die veröffentlichung
zurück jedes ministerium solle seinen
beitrag zum klimaschutz selbst bestimmen
so die absprache im kabinett es zeigt
vor allem dass diese regierung nicht
wirklich zusammen arbeitet es ist ein
dokument wo zwei parteien versucht haben
gemeinsamen kompromiss untereinander zu
finden oder den kompromiss den müssen
sie machen mit der naturwissenschaft
denn sie mal mit dem klimaschutz und
diesem kompromiss scheint sich die spd
nicht mehr so sehr verpflichtet zu
fühlen
die designierten parteivorsitzenden der
spd esken und walter borjans kündigten
an die klimaziele mit der cdu neu
verhandeln zu wollen
das wichtig dass solche papiere
entstehen und dann auch das licht der
öffentlichkeit erblicken weil sie ganz
deutlich aufzeigen wie weit wir doch in
manchen maßnahmen in den bereichen von
dem entfernt sind was getan werden muss
um dann eben tatsächlich die ziele die
wir ja schon verabredet haben zu
erreichen
die pläne aus dem umweltbundesamt dürfte
der spd-spitze wohl gelegen kommen und
so birgt eine sechs monate alte studie
plötzlich neuen sprengstoff für die
große koalition
wir werden sie die nachrichten von
gundula gause
jetzt ist es beschlossen das
us-repräsentantenhaus bereitet ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen präsident
trump vor
der justizausschuss hat offiziell den
auftrag die anklagepunkte zu formulieren
die demokratische vorsitzende des
repräsentantenhauses pelosi erklärte
trump habe in der ukraine affäre
eindeutig zu seinem eigenen politischen
vorteil seine macht missbraucht und
damit die nationale sicherheit der usa
in gefahr gebracht die entscheidung aber
wird im senat falle nun dort haben
trumps republikaner die mehrheit
die innenminister der länder halten
zunächst am abschiebestopp für syrische
flüchtlinge fest und haben ihn bis ende
juni 2020 verlängert zugleich wollen sie
die bundesregierung auffordern die
voraussetzungen für die abschiebung von
gefährden und straftätern zu schaffen
außerdem haben die innenminister über
eine bessere koordination im kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus beraten
deutschland zählt bei der
erwachsenenbildung zu den führenden
ländern weltweit die unesco lobt die
bundesrepublik gehöre zu den wenigen
ländern die über vier prozent ihres
bildungsbudgets in die weiterbildung
investieren
weltweit müsse aber mehr für die
erwachsenenbildung getan werden vor
allem migranten und menschen mit
behinderung hätten es schwer sich
fortzubilden
in der kontroverse um das umstrittene
unkrautvernichtungsmittel glyphosat
zieht der hersteller monsanto der heute
dem deutschen bayer konzern gehört
erneut kritik auf sich
vor einigen jahren hatte monsanto zwei
glyphosat studien in deutschland
mitfinanziert ohne dies kenntlich zu
machen
die studien des gießener instituts für
agribusiness beschrieben den
wirtschaftlichen nutzen von glyphosat
das sei eine inakzeptable verdeckte
einflussnahme kritisiert der verein
lobbycontrol
es geht jetzt um bildung um die rechte
von schülern und eltern mit denen es
viel zu langsam voran geht vor zwei
jahren hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
ein aufregendes urteil gefällt das ist
nämlich nicht so weitergeht mit abitur
und hochschulzugang junge leute werden
an einer entscheidenden weichenstellung
ihres lebens unfair behandelt um ihre
chancen gebracht das system 16
bundesländer mit völlig
unterschiedlichen anforderungen muss
demnach geändert werden
ein nationaler bildungsrat sollte das
jetzt richten
der wurde erst beschlossen und jetzt
anderthalb jahre später wieder abgeräumt
alles wieder auf null stefanie dosch
über fortschritt im tempo deutscher
kulturpolitik büffeln für das abitur in
einem der top gymnasien in berlin
die 1,3 abschlussquote an ihrer schule
hoch anders als an den brennpunktschulen
dennoch haben sie oft das gefühl dass
ihre ausbildung weniger wert ist als
etwa in bayern was sie sich vom
bildungssystem daher wünschen dass einem
halt überall der gleiche lehrstoff zur
gleichen zeit unterrichtet wird und dass
gleichwertigkeit gilt und gleich
bewertungskriterien ja also ich finde
auf jeden fall die chancengleichheit in
dem sinne ist nicht da und es liegt ja
nur daran dass ich in berlin wohne und
dadurch habe ich einfach schulisch nicht
die gleiche voraussetzungen
das sieht auch rektor ralf treptow so er
leitet seit 28 jahren das rosa luxemburg
gymnasium die bisherigen beschlüsse der
kultusministerkonferenz kritisiert er
wünscht sich die normierung die
vereinheitlichung des abiturs ich glaube
dass das zentralabitur die der einzige
weg ist um das deutsche bildungsweg
wieder zu wir sind wieder zunehme
wir müssen uns einige wie die wie die
abschluss standards sind wir müssen auf
uns auf einheitliche prüfungen einigen
wenn wir warten das alles davor erst mal
in angriff genommen wird dann warten wir
noch weitere 100 jahre
laut der kultusministerkonferenz warten
die schüler weiter auf das zentralabitur
neun frauen und sieben männer
kultusminister der länder entschieden
dies heute kein großer umbruch sondern
kleine schritte wir erarbeiten unser
abituraufgaben polizei weiter aus wir
arbeiten auch an der vereinheitlichung
der termine also wir bewegen uns schon
auf zusehens einheitliche standards
möglicherweise auf gemeinsame abitur
klausuren hin aber ein bundesweites
zentralabitur nach französischem vorbild
das werde auf absehbare zeit nicht
bekommen und das brauchen wir auch
ehrlich gesagt nicht dabei sollte
eigentlich ein gremium von vertretern
des bundes der länder und experten ein
sogenannter nationaler bildungsrat die
vereinheitlichung des abiturs
beschleunigen
doch bayern und baden württemberg
stiegen aus nun soll es einen
bildungsrat bzw
wissenschaftlichen beirat geben der
entscheidende unterschied der bund
bleibt weitgehend außen vor
das problem des nationalen bildungsrat
zwar ist das ist unter federführung des
bundes erfolgte länderhoheit in der
bildung im föderalen system so die
zentrale grundlage und ist aus bayern
baden württemberg und anderen
das signal gekommen und möchte keine
einmischung des bundes haben
der nationale bildungsrat der im
koalitionsvertrag auf bundesebene
angedacht war
er stellte für diese länder die gefahr
dass der bund sich einmischt diese
gefahr habe ich nicht gesehen
doch der neue entwurf fand eine mehrheit
die schüler in berlin mag trösten dass
beim zugang zur universität oft vor
allem die bestnote zählt ob abitur in
berlin oder anderswo professor michael
piazolo ist ein mann der freien wähler
in bayern und in diesem freistaat der
kultusminister einen schönen guten abend
nach berlin
ein schwenk oder abenteuerlich aber
anderthalb jahre haben die bundesländer
jetzt versucht einen nationalen
bildungsrat auf die beine zu stellen der
die dinge ein bisschen einheitlicher
regeln soll in deutschland und jetzt
machen sie baden württemberg und bayern
davon was soll dieser rückfall
die kleinstaaterei es ist keine
kleinstaaterei sondern sie haben es
schon gesagt wenn man so lange
miteinander redet und insbesondere auch
über stimmenverteilung und in vielen
dingen auch kleinigkeiten dann ist es
einfach mal richtig irgendwann zu sagen
das ist nicht der richtige ansatz
und deshalb haben wir die reißleine
gezogen aber wir haben auch der
alternative angeboten nämlich gesagt der
rat an sich also die expertise von
experten ist gut und deshalb wollen wir
dass ausländer ebene im rahmen der
kultusministerkonferenz aufsetzen und
darüber haben wir heute auch gesprochen
nun ist ja dieser nationale bildungsrat
mich irgendwie frei erfunden worden
sondern das war eine antwort auf eine
forderung des bundesverfassungsgerichts
das den 16 ländern aufgegeben hat dafür
zu sorgen dass in deutschland etwas
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
hergestellt werden bei der bildung
nun haben sie sich anderthalb jahre lang
aus gemehrt und jetzt wollen sie
plötzlich diesen diesen rat reduzieren
auf einen beirat von 16 ministern die
weiterhin völlig unterschiedlicher
ansicht sind und wahrscheinlich dann
früher oder später in alle richtungen
wieder davon gehen nein es ist eine
erstens wissenschaftler sein die uns
beraten als landesminister das ist das
eine zum zweiten wollen wir das ganze
auch noch flankieren mit einem
übereinkommen zur bildungs und
schulpolitik dass auch die
rahmenbedingungen schafft um genau diese
vergleichbaren lebensverhältnisse
herzustellen bei hohem qualitätsstandard
das ist uns insbesondere an bayern auch
sehr wichtig nun sieht man aber wieder
mal dass es bayern und baden württemberg
sind die diesel an diesen konsens als
erster aufgekündigt haben das sind die
beiden länder die sich schon mal von
anfang an auf die pole position bei den
ferien gelegt haben nämlich die späten
ferien die unter anderem dafür sorgen
dass bayerische abiturienten ein paar
wochen länger zeit haben sich aufs
abitur vorzubereiten und die anderen
sollen mal gucken wie sie sich
koordinieren
es ist doch ziemlich eindeutig dass zwei
so bildungseliten länder eine mia san
mir politik machen und eben nicht
mitmachen wollen bei der schaffung
gleichwertiger lebensverhältnisse
ganz so ist es nicht die ferienregelung
gilt schon sehr lange
und sie ist gemeinsam unter allen
ländern damals verabschiedet worden
bewusst mit baden württemberg und bayern
am ende die das so wollten aber die
anderen haben auch nichts dagegen gehabt
es hat auch pädagogische gründe wir
haben in bayern späte und lange
pfingstferien dann brauchen wir die zeit
bis zu den späten sommerferien um
einfach die prüfung durch zu ziehen und
uns entsprechend vorzubereiten
also das macht alles sinn so wie es
jetzt ist und deshalb wollen und werden
wir auch dabei bleiben
ihre kollegin frau eisenmann die ja wie
ihn wie sie selbst auch diese nationalen
bildungsrat verlassen hat die hat gerade
ziemlich deutlich beim wort genannten
hat gesagt im grunde wollten wir den
bund nicht dabei haben wir länder das
ist nochmal uns bereit wir wollen das
selber regeln aber haben sie nicht lang
genug bewiesen dass jedoch ein bisschen
erwachsener aufsicht brauchen um zu
lösungen zu kommen denn die 16 auf sich
selbst gestellt kriegen es ja offenbar
auch nicht hin da doch die 16 länder
haben seit vielen jahren auch eine gute
bildungspolitik gemacht wir sitzen vier
mal drei mal oder viermal im jahr in
berlin zusammen zwischendurch sind ist
auch die amtschefs viele arbeits ronda
ist man gut vorangekommen in
verschiedenen bereichen
wir haben jetzt die digitalisierung auch
nach vorne gebracht schule man auch mal
mit mit hilfe des bundes und mit geld
des bundes das ist mit geld des bundes
passiert aber gerade auch in bayern
haben wir vorher schon ein programm
gehabt mit über 200 millionen
auch in anderen bereichen gerade die
gleichwertigen lebensverhältnisse
angesprochen haben wir ein programm
aufgesetzt schule macht stark dass sich
gerade in den sozialen brennpunkten
schulen widmen sollen also die
kultusminister die können schon ihre
aufgabe und sie machen es manchmal läuft
es vielleicht unter dem schirm oder
radar der öffentlichkeit aber wir sind
da sehr zuversichtlich und haben gerade
heute auch sehr viele positive
beschlüsse gefällt
in ein zwei jahren werden die menschen
in deutschland bundesweit merken die
schere ist kleiner geworden
ich hoffe es daran arbeiten wir das ist
auch ganz wichtig wir dürfen niemanden
in den schulen verlieren jeder braucht
auch seine ausbildung und seinen
abschluss denn nur dann hat man gute
chancen im berufsleben und das
auch unsere gesellschaft zusammen
insofern ist er sein kernthema ein ganz
wichtiges dessen sind wir uns bewusst
dessen bin ich mehr als kultusminister
bewusst und deshalb gilt da unsere
anstrengung hier möglichst gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse herzustellen
piazolo danke für das gespräch einen
schönen abend ich danke hiernach wir
haben das gespräch vor ein paar stunden
geführt weil herr piazolo noch am abend
von berlin zurück nach münchen musste
oder vielleicht wollte beides
verständlich nachrichten aus der
wirtschaft an der frankfurter börse wird
die übernahme von osram mit großer
spannung verfolgt der österreichische
sensorspezialist ams kämpft im zweiten
anlauf um den leuchtmittelhersteller und
gegen hedgefonds frank bethmann welche
konsequenzen hat der übernahmepoker denn
für osram selbst davon der übernahme
hängt maßgeblich ab wie es weitergeht
das renommierte licht unternehmen
befindet sich in einer wirtschaftlichen
schieflage und ist auch deswegen
innerhalb weniger monate hier an der
börse zu einem spekulationsobjekt
geworden
das traditionsunternehmen wurde bereits
bekannt durch werbung als diese noch
reklame hieß produziert heute aber nicht
mehr die weltbekannten glühbirnen
sondern hat sich spezialisiert auf leds
für die smartphone und
automobilindustrie
doch dieser markt ist umkämpft und nun
will das kleinere unternehmen ams das
größere schlucken ein kraftakt für die
österreicher die bereits einmal damit
gescheitert sind auch der zweite anlauf
steht jetzt auf der kippe
wenige stunden vor ablauf des
übernahmeangebots um mitternacht hat ams
rund 40 prozent der osram aktien sicher
als erfolgreich gilt dieser versuch aber
erst bei 55 zählern an der waage dürften
jetzt in den verbleibenden zwei stunden
hedgefonds seien die knapp die hälfte
der osram anteile zusammen gekauft haben
sie spekulieren nun auf ein gutes
angebot von ams andernfalls könnte auch
der zweite anlauf scheitern und wie so
oft wenn investoren um geld und macht
zocken könnten die osram mitarbeiter die
leidtragenden seien rund 800 stellen
stehen nach angaben der gewerkschaft auf
dem spiel das würde bedeuten
jeder siebte der 5600 beschäftigten in
deutschland bangt um seinen job
danke frank widmann
für diesen informationen der
saudiarabische ölkonzern aramco peilt
den größten börsengang aller zeiten an
rund 23 milliarden euro will das
unternehmen an der börse von riad
einsammeln gab der konzern bekannt
aramco würde damit auf einen börsenwert
von insgesamt rund 1 5 billionen euro
kommen und apple als weltweit
wertvollstes unternehmen ablösen
die rettung der angeschlagenen
norddeutschen landesbank ist einen
wichtigen schritt vorangekommen
die eu kommission hat milliardenschwere
kapitalhilfen genehmigt niedersachsen
sachsen anhalt und die sparkassengruppe
wollen bis jahresende 2,8 milliarden
euro in die nord lb investieren
wegen ausfallgefährdeter schiffskredite
kämpft die landesbank mit hohen
verlusten und befindet sich in einem
tiefgreifenden wandel immer mehr
beschäftigte in deutschland melden sich
wegen psychischer probleme und störungen
krank und die zahl der mit psychischen
erkrankungen begründeten fehltage hat
sich laut dem aktuellen
gesundheitsreport der
betriebskrankenkassen binnen zehn jahren
mehr als verdoppelt auf pro fall
37 fehltage im vergangenen jahr am
häufigsten blieben arbeitnehmer aber
wegen rücken- und gelenkschmerzen zu
hause oder auch wegen grippe und
atemwegserkrankungen im schnitt 18 5
tage im jahr
bei uns geht es weiter mit politik von
harter kannte jedenfalls hat maybrit
illner das thema fein zugespitzt fordern
drohen falschen ob das das letzte
weihnachten der groko wird wir sagen
weihnachten ist noch weit und wir sehen
uns morgen bis dann zwischen alt
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute möchte ich
ihnen eine maskierte kaltfront
vorstellen das habe ich hier mit diesen
namen kappen symbolisiert denn diese
kaltfront ist sowas wie getarnt sie
bringt keine kältere luft mit sondern
deutlich mildere mit dem tief quentin
das ist jetzt im winter sehr oft der
fall weil es vor so einer front oft sehr
sehr kalt sein kann und diese kalt von
die wird besonders gefährlich sie bringt
regen mit und der kann dann auf
gefrorenem boden fallen dann geht es
gefrierenden regen schauen wir uns genau
an jetzt in der nacht sinken die
temperaturen auf minus ein bis minus 7
grad milder bleibt die nach dem
nordwesten bei 5 bis 2 grad dort wird
also der regen der nacht weniger fällt
doch auch nicht gefrorenen boden es wird
dabei stürmisch es gibt auch wieder
nebelfelder in süddeutschland und morgen
dann liegen zwar die höchsttemperaturen
bei ein bis zehn grad aber besonders am
vormittag bleibt es doch lange frostig
am boden in der mitte deutschlands und
dann geht er los der wettlauf zwischen
der milderen temperaturen und dem regen
und wenn der regen gewinnt dann fällt er
auf gefrorenem boden und es wird
spiegelglatt
das kann in thüringen in hessen
rheinland pfalz und im saarland der fall
sein
am längsten sonnig ist es morgen in
sachsen und in bayern
sonst wird es stürmisch regnerisch und
das sind auch die aussichten für das
zweite adventswochenende wie sie hier
sehen können erst in der neuen woche
wird es deutlich kälter mit schnee in
den mittelgebirgen
schönen abend noch